Hey, what's up guys it's Rob, and welcome
to my tutorial for:
The Ninja Tristar Boomerang!
On my last Ninja Star
Boomerang video, I got some requests to
try to do a three-pointed boomerang and
after some trials and fails, I finally
came up with this one that flies like
this:
I also called and challenged Jeremy Shafer
to try to make his own
boomerang and he made one that flies just like this:
You can check out his
video by clicking the card above or the
link in the description. After you learn
how to make it and also throw it like I
show at the end of the video, people are
really gonna want one. So if you do enjoy
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter slice
printer paper like this which will then
can have their own and they don't have
to try to take yours. I'm using an
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter sized
printer paper like this which we'll then
turn into a triangle with three equal
sides. This is also known as an
equilateral triangle and each side is
9.75" or nine and
three-quarter inches long. That makes the
height basically the width of the paper
which is eight and a half inches. Knowing
all this here's the bonus comment. Now
your dimensions of the triangle are
correct to make an equilateral triangle
we can use any size rectangle like I
said I'm using eight and a half by
your dimensions of the triangle are
correct. To make an equilateral triangle
we can use any size rectangle. Like I
said, I'm using eight and a half by
neatly as possible hold it there and
make a crease on the left side then you
can open it back up and this next fold
is the most important we're going to
neatly as possible. Hold it there and
make a crease on the left side. Then you
can open it back up and this next fold
is the most important. We're going to
corner along the middle there until that
top edge lines up with the upper-left
top edge here is lined up from the middle all the
way to the upper left so just slide the
crease all throughout the right side
like that here you can see the upper
corner just like that. Once you have
it positioned there then you can make a
crease all throughout the right side
like that. Here you can see the upper
using letter size paper like me then you
can make a mark on the middle here
with the middle and upper left. If you
are better with measurements and you're
here all the way to the upper left and
that should measure eight and a half
then you could just take the right
corner here fold it directly on to that
here all the way to the upper left and
that should measure eight and a half.
Then you could just take the right
corner here fold it directly on to that
line and go from there.
Once you have that fold, we're going to
like this once you have it lined up like
that then you can make another crease on
the right side I like to tear it but if
you do want to cut it that's fine I'm
like this. Once you have it lined up like
that then you can make another crease on
the right side. I like to tear it but if
you do want to cut it that's fine. I'm
over I'm going to start the tear here on
top and just pull the two edges apart do
fingernail on the left. Then I'm going to
open both of the edges up and flip it
over. I'm going to start the tear here on
top and just pull the two edges apart do
you'll notice that all sides are the
same and it looks the same no matter
you have an equilateral triangle. If you
made the equilateral triangle properly,
down on this crease we already have here
it should wind up directly in the middle
which way you hold it. If you take the
top corner of the triangle and fold it
three corners or vertices in these
directions we can take the bottom left
of the bottom side. Now we're going to
split the triangle in half along its
three corners or vertices in these
directions. We can take the bottom left
line it up like this you could hold it
and make a crease on the left side then
meeting them up like this and also
meeting up the two edges here. Once you
line it up like this you can hold it
and make a crease on the left side then
you could open it up again. Now we can
do the same with the other corners. Take
should have something like this and I'm
just going to draw on the new creases
take the bottom right meet it to the top
as well and do the same thing. So now you
should have something like this. I'm
just going to draw on the new creases
that we just made so you could see them
easier.
At the middle of the triangle there's an
intersection point and from that
determine the width of the airfoil flap
on the front and because we want all
"side lines". I've drawn those in red. The
next folds are important and will
determine the width of the "Air Foil" flaps
on the front, and because we want all
three equal, I recommend you use a ruler.
On the red side lines I'm going to make
three marks a quarter inch from the
center. Here's one, there's two, and
there's three. Don't forget that the
quarter inch is this one right here.
We're now going to take all three sides
and fold them directly on to the points
that we made on the side lines here. I'm
just going to rotate it like this so
crease along the top and I'm just gonna
make it nice and sharp by running my
point here directly on to that top point
that I have. Then, I'm going to make a
do the same with this one so just fold
the second one down to the point and
fingernail against it. Then, we could open
it up and I'm just going to rotate it now.
Do the same with this one. So just fold
the second one down to the point and
give it a sharp crease on top, and then
you could open it rotate it and fold the
last one down. Give it a sharp crease.
Now you can unfold it, and you should
have something that looks like this.
We're now going to take this bottom
right corner and we're just going to
pinch it together like this. Just take
take the bottom edge and the right edge
and press them in like this so that
against it like this. Then, we're
going to set it down and we're going to
sticking up once these two edges are
both flattened down we're going to take
this corner here that we've been holding
on to and then just pull the corner down
sticking up. Once these two edges are
both flattened down, we're going to take
then we can just open it up and we're
just going to rotate it so that this
like this and then make a crease right
around here.
Then, we can just open it up and we're
just going to rotate it so that this
edge is now on the bottom. Then we can
do the same thing: pinch the bottom right
corner, make sure it's aligned on both
sides, and then flatten the bottom and
corner flatten the edges and pull the
corner down and flatten it so
flatten it out. Then we could work on the
last one. Just rotate it, pinch the
corner, flatten the edges, and pull the
corner down and flatten it. So,
everything's going to be put in a
clockwise direction like this. Just
put all the corners and the edges like
that. As you'll see, they're kind of going
in this direction and flatten it out. So
you should have something that looks
just like. So I'm just gonna flip it over
like this, and you'll see here we have
those three marks on the back. That's not
what we're going to be paying attention
to for this next step. We're actually
going to be making a mark in the center
of the paper right here. We're going
to hold the triangle so that the point
is facing down like this, and we're going
to be taking this edge here and folding
edge and bring it down like this
straight down to the middle and make
paper. So just set it down on the table. I'm just going to take this whole
right here where the crease is and walk
your finger to the left and this might
sure that this fold stays on top of
itself. Now when you do that just hold it
right here where the crease is and walk
your finger to the left. This might
try to lift up, what you can do is just
go like this and flatten it out first
and then really flatten it on top like
that. We're just going to walk our
finger up to this point right here, you
don't want to fold this down. We're
and we're just gonna rotate it and do
the same exact thing take the next edge
give it a good crease from here all the
way to the end. Then you can open it up
and we're just gonna rotate it and do
the same exact thing. Take the next edge
right point that's sticking up same
thing with the last one we're just gonna
left, flatten the edge out, and then press
down in that little pocket behind the
right point that's sticking up. Same
thing with the last one. We're just gonna
fold the edge all the way down to the
middle and walk our fingers to the left.
As you'll see there's a little overhang
on the left side, and then you could just
we closed it down in a clockwise
direction except this time what's going
this now. We're gonna do the same
thing that we did on the other side when
we closed it down in a clockwise
direction, except this time what's going
to be in a counterclockwise direction as
you'll see here, I tore it a little bit
but it shouldn't be a problem. That was
just when I
used the pen. We're just gonna press down
like this so that this edge is
then you can open these two and do the
same thing twist it clockwise fold down
see these two edges meet in the middle. Then just flatten it out like that.
Then you can open these two and do the
same thing twist it clockwise fold down
on this bottom edge and also on the top
edge. Push right here and then push
right here, and press down in the middle
all the way down like that.
Open it, twist it clockwise, push down on
the bottom edge and make sure that these
two edges stay together. Press down until
it goes all the way to the middle. All
flip it over like this and I'm going to
fold this over hang down all the way
it should be in a counterclockwise
direction. Flatten it out. Now we could
flip it over like this and I'm going to
fold this overhang down all the way
down to here. So I'll zoom in so you can
see it. I'm gonna take this, fold it all
the way down even in the corner where it
doesn't want to go. Just kind of press it
especially in the corner you can kind of
just give it a little tug and fold it
good crease. Rotate it do the same
exact thing. Fold it all the way down
to press it down as far down as you can
but don't pull too hard do the last one
down just like that. So it will be a
little bit angled, that's okay just try
to press it down as far down as you can
but don't pull too hard. Do the last one.
And you're all done and I'll show you
how to make the boomerang fly really
well and how to throw it. So, I'm going to
show you why we need to make sure that
it's really neat and we have to adjust
it . So I just finished this one.
I'm going to hold it with the flaps on
the left and give it a shot. Okay so it kind
of fell to the ground and didn't come back.
Looking at the boomerang, I can kind of
see that these are sticking up. So what
I'm going to do is first hold it with
my fingernails then I'm just gonna lift
it up and as you can see here I'm just
making sure it's nice and flat,
creasing both edges of the arms with
my fingernails. Then I'm just gonna lift
it up and as you can see here I'm just
gonna crease every single airfoil or
flap with my fingernail very sharply.
Now what I'm going to do is holding the
flaps facing downwards like this on the
table I'm gonna take my finger, my
pointer and thumb, and I'm gonna round
so curl the wings and the tips a little
bit away from the flaps I'd like that
much just like that. Do that with all
three of them.
Curl the wings and the tips a little
bit away from the flaps side like that.
Alright so let's see how it flies now. I'm going to hold it between my
airfoil right about there
and I'm gonna hold it between my pointer
not on the tip. I'm going to hold it
right at the edge or the end of the
Air Foil right about there. I'm gonna hold it between my pointer
and middle finger like this making sure
that the flaps are facing to the left.
I'm going to curl my wrist like this
and I'm going to basically flick it out
like that and let it roll out of my hand.
so I'm going to throw it kind of
vertically tilt it a little bit to the
left. Let's give it a shot
There you go that's much better. The one
that I made with eleven by seventeen
inch paper flies a little bit better
actually.
Thanks for watching my video for the new
Ninja Tri-Star boomerang. I hope you
Paper boomerangs can be really sensitive
to bends and stuff like that in the
paper, so if you find it flying funky
after a few throws you'll have to
re-flatten it, sharpen the creases again and
also fix the tips to make it fly well
again. Let me know what you thought of
the video in the comments below and also
what you'd like to see next and I might
try to make it.
thanks and I'll see you next time